[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we are doing a
very special hot seat you've been
waiting for it we have geo in the
[Music]
you have to wait throne it gino
how does this work what do i do okay so
basically you're just gonna sit there
we're gonna try our best to ask you some
very very exciting questions that
everybody's been waiting to hear about
but we of course have to warm it up
we're gonna start off real cold from um
your wife uh let's go ahead
if
you were blind okay
and you stuck your hand in a bucket okay
and the bucket was filled between soil
or wet coffee grounds would you be able
to tell different
soil or wet coffee yeah you could tell
it i feel like the the coffee grounds
would be super coarse
really like sandy
really
i'm so surprised your relationship made
it this way
you guys are on the same way he keeps me
on my toes you guys get it
you get it that's the best answer for me
you get it
make them warmer baby all right so you
saw the clips where like taiko was here
during the hosting right yeah i was i
was right there do you remember yeah do
you remember when uh he was asking like
who do you love more like mommy or your
dad and he would say daddy how did you
really feel about that stuff no no it's
i mean he we know the truth right me and
tiger we talk about we talk about it
talk about how like how strong our bond
is together and then i go hey but you're
gonna make your dad really sad so let's
just publicly say
that he's your favorite oh
so
sorry to to have to tell you like this
yeah um but that's what happened he also
had that talk with his son she's just
being an ally for men's mental health
yeah dude i am thank you
so empathetic do you agree
yeah clearly
how does he have this shadow like he's
got like little whiskers but there's
nothing there
he's making his own you look like that
like trademark logo of that happy face
which one the yellow one
[Laughter]
dude we're gonna get banned for you
making that face
cease and desist someone owns that face
bro so why'd you leave jk
why did i leave jk yeah oh
real that's the deal
uh because i became a mom dude i pushed
the [ __ ] human out of my vagina and i
wanted to spend a lot of time uh with
him
tmi though
what's your most embarrassing moment
[Laughter]
stupid the editors could be like what
the [ __ ] happened to the audio there so
they cut out
[ __ ]
i don't know i i don't know i don't know
if i have one i have i think my whole
life is embarrassing
um i don't know whenever you do
something i'm really embarrassed what's
something that's embarrassing to you
that you felt like uh like earlier on
you're like oh man oh she didn't happen
but later on i'm so glad that like you
never like [ __ ] while dead lifting or
anything no i've never shot while dead
lifting sounds like you don't deadlift
enough
probably you know dead looked hard no
you need to up the weight a little bit
you're not hardcore brah i don't know i
don't know i think i do a lot of [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ] but like i don't know if
i'm like really embarrassed have i told
you about him what about her no no like
a kid or something you know nothing like
crazy happened or as a teen and you and
you turned all hot in your ears like no
one look at me don't look at me maybe
like i've had like a period leak like
and i was wearing some like light pants
we've all had that yeah
we'll come back to this we'll come back
today that was pretty rough so so now
that you you are settled in the las
vegas area right and then you have this
whole new life
and you used to be here pretty much
seven days a week
yeah here like a jk jk we used to film
all this stuff every single day right
how is life now
that all you do is chill with taika and
you don't do jack [ __ ] what do you do
well that's not true tiger's at school
and i and i do all barbell brigade stuff
so that's a lot of my time sounds boring
but
but definitely
it's definitely sad times because i do
miss like [ __ ] around seeing you guys
wearing my clothes that's what i thought
wearing makeup
uh so life is not the same absolutely
not like that was for sure peak like fun
times why don't you come back then yeah
well we don't do any of that stuff
anymore
i'll wear a blouse that you guys yeah
thank you
i'm right here i'm right in front of you
do you not see me i'm being insecure
because i miss you emotionally okay so
can we move past that so how does it
feel now that you're back do you still
go oh but it won't last like it used to
because i'm not always here and you feel
sad no i like it
because of his emotional status do you
need a hug no i'm just trying to make
you [ __ ] emotional because we need
drama oh okay
i love everyone's energy like everyone
has like a really unique take on [ __ ] um
and it does make me a little bit sad
that i can't be here all the time that's
awesome
because you can't come back
but let me let me let me elaborate on
something you wanted me to open up so
you could [ __ ] stab me in the heart
let me elaborate on something that was
very juicy and i loved hearing it was
like music to my ears when you said you
know what you guys are like all star
team and i don't feel like i belong
anymore and i'm like yes we are [ __ ]
we are the harlem globetrotters of
[ __ ] comedy
we're never in the nba but we're just
good
you know oh i see yeah
yeah i feel like i didn't i shouldn't
have been there yeah it changed yeah
because you guys gelled so well like the
[ __ ] energy and the vibes were so
good that i'm like oh i need to step out
of this one this is nice like i just
need to be a viewer but you know you're
always welcome back this is home for you
yeah i invited myself i know i know i
invited you but then i forgot that i did
and i didn't want you here but you're
welcome here but then i just wanna i
just i do you feel like
that's true like you don't really belong
anymore how does that no no no i don't
really feel that but i feel like what
you guys have done now since like
there's been so much like uh cash change
up that it's been like really cool like
like the way because like we never
really hung out with you guys like us
three were doing a bunch of [ __ ]
together for many years so it's like
natural that we like really clicked
really well but then for like you three
for example to like really come in and
like and gel as well as you guys do i'm
like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] tight
that's awesome let's say your mom dies
[Laughter]
your mom too dog yeah let's say you're
at her funeral right
and it's open casket i just did
something so nice
we've been waiting you know there's a
lot of people he didn't hear [ __ ]
he just thought about it oh it's a light
bulb
that's the most uncomfortable i've ever
felt
okay
obviously you're sad who's not sad when
their parents passed away right you're
[ __ ] sad you're sad too i'm [ __ ]
sad too both of your mom's yeah yeah i'm
sad too what
but out of the out of the 99.99
you're sad
what's the point zero zero what'd you
marry this guy one percent where you go
like that and you go
you're all crying and [ __ ] you're like
i [ __ ] told you [ __ ]
you ever i told you some moment
now you're like we never saw eye to eye
on this
and i knew i was right you're saying it
out loud in front of the whole funeral
by the way yeah
open casket and you're you're mine for
some reason you're mugged up
you're mighty
[Laughter]
uh so the moment she said i shouldn't
marry bart and i was like see i told you
[ __ ] she was gonna be good she told you
this moment
i reveal it here yeah
like see mommy's a good guy i told you
[ __ ] cuts to all the videos on jk what
did you have against me huh what did you
have against me i don't know a lot of
things actually what what is
uh if anything your families or like
your funniest uh perspective of bart
like something that they maybe don't
like or uh didn't like in the beginning
well they love everything about part but
it did so he's not the first asian guy
that i dated um oh drama no uh so the
first
everyone
so the first one just because of you i'm
gonna make the [ __ ] tativa bigger
dude he got a tattoo
he thought he said
fear no one but it says fear everyone
yeah he google translated that
uh and got it what what state was it
carolina in north carolina catch johnson
somebody just reads his life like dude
joe's mom joe's mom read it and yeah so
he told this that says
everyone knows this because we keep
telling it over and over
but also everybody knows not to google
translate have somebody actually not the
language but in 2004 you know all right
so in 2004
me and my best friend we just scratched
you know two people have this tattoo
two people have this tattoo
you got it and it's right here dude it's
right here yeah so me and my best friend
2004 we just got out of boot camp and
you're super motivated you know you're
like i can conquer the world i feel like
warriors and [ __ ] so we're like you know
we're hold my hand dude we're [ __ ]
best buds man we're the best buds so
we're like we got to get something you
know that's something that that that
exemplifies that so
we're in north carolina and we're the
only two asians there of course amazing
amazing great choices and so we're like
what we gotta get some of this tough oh
i know fear no one oh i like that one
like that too today's video is brought
to you by babble
so right now i've been missing some
international travel
and um back in last july me and hannah
went to mexico right so for our
anniversary i took her to a mexican
fair slash concert flash like slash
outside bazaar
shopping place food fair it was pretty
amazing right and we were there and i
feel like we were the only
non-hispanic
and we stuck out like a sore thumb but
everyone was super nice they were just
like oh cool you want to try this
whatever
and i really missed speaking spanish but
i didn't want to be super like offensive
but thanks to babble i was able to look
it up real quick and get myself brushed
up on all the stuff and be like okay i
feel confident again let me experiment
on using spanish with my fellow espanols
over here's yeah and then what happened
it'll work they're like i speak english
fools
i use babble to learn english
but no there was it was pretty cool
because like you know they knew that i
was just trying to practice and stuff
and so they're super supportive but
that's what i really like about babel is
they have so many different languages
that you can learn from what's really
cool is they do it in these real quick
10-minute lessons yeah they're really
quick and because they're so easy to
digest you can start speaking and having
conversations like in real life like not
those crazy like super official words
but actual conversational vocabulary
words in less than three weeks and it
was created by over 150 language experts
yeah and they even have speech
recognition technology so it can help
you correct your enunciations you can
pronounce things better and better and
better and you can choose from 14
different languages like spanish italian
french german
all kinds of languages right now you can
save up to 60 off your subscription yeah
when you go to babble.com off the record
that's babble.com off the record for up
to 60 off your subscription babble
language for life essay okay cool so
we're like but i'm chinese my best
friend's korean nice we can't be like
i'll get a chinese one because then it's
almost like like he got my name tattooed
on him and if i got korean it's almost
like i got his name tattooed you're best
friends yeah because we're holding hands
so they had we got to meet in the middle
in the middle so what's what's neutral
that's so funny oh japanese that's
pretty neutral
cool we'll go to the computer lab on
base excuse me are you done with your
computer and then we go
google translate we go
fear no one and it was like
like
oh
i don't know what it says but i trust
google translate you're gonna lie so
they printed it out yeah this looks
tight print i can see this on my shin
bone you know
take the paper i'm so happy go to the
tattoo shop that's so happy and then
we're like hey mister get your tattoo on
both of us
and he's like just let you know i don't
read
what was his ethnicity his wife
i don't read no orangutan
i love how deeper every single time
she's got more more details more details
[Music]
he was tooting i want that guy to tattoo
me great armadillo man and then so we
got it tattooed and then we came back
i was hanging out with joe years later
years later later yeah and that's when
his mom was like
what what's he's what's he scared of
yeah because we were in the living room
and then she was like pointing at his
leg she goes what is he so scared of and
i'm like hilarious and i'm like what do
you mean he goes it says he's scared of
everyone
[Laughter]
so it's supposed to be supposed to be
fear no one but then i think i switched
around so it's like everyone fear or
something like that i got the phone up
yeah the phone for everyone literally
everyone google translate did it
fear everyone
not with the typing yeah yeah yeah
i'm scared of everyone now
back a geo's hot seat
bart does that to me all the time i'm
using them
but you but you had brother but you had
brought up that you were he was the
second asian guy that you would yeah why
did i bring that up oh yeah so what did
your family didn't like about me
impressions of him so like with that guy
that was like their first introduction
to like like deep asian culture right
like me yeah yeah yeah so my grandma i
remember asking she's like what do they
eat all day like like dogs
egg girls like what's going on like they
would just ask like it was it was
definitely just out of ignorance it was
culture night and then i had like all
this pride i'm like what the [ __ ] you
mean like i obviously not with that kind
of added to me i'm like what are you
talking about like they're american they
just eat like american food would you
would you eat hamburgers too
made hot dogs hot dogs sticks
yeah so that was like that was like
their introduction to um to like the
asian culture so when he came around
they were like of course you know and
then bart picks up a hamburger with
chopsticks and they're like ah she was
right we've seen this before but what
about me specifically
like is there a personality trait like
man this guy always does this he's like
i was just the second asian guy
so the one so so i think my brother was
it was like a really so he would watch
all of our stuff right like he would
watch jk party jk films she can use and
he knows like every character every
person he knew that before we got
together no but he you didn't really
meet him until years later like meet him
meet him like you knew like you guys
would talk but then when you guys got
closer was like after we got married
true yeah okay all right maybe i'm
making [ __ ] up um so then so then when
he really met you he was like really sad
because he's this like he's like bart's
not like the same like on video that he
is in person because like in person
bart's bart's like this in person yeah
that's his personality every [ __ ]
party he's like yeah that's true
that is true so my brother would like
try to throw jokes at him and try to
like banter and my and he just would be
like like wanted nothing to do with it
and he goes to sleep at 9 00 p.m exactly
the energy level is down so he'd be like
i don't think bart likes me very much
like he doesn't like play around with me
and like he doesn't play mafia with me
just imagine her brother being like a
knock knock it embargo one
bart's
what happened to you man you're my hero
i subscribed man
does he talk like that no i subscribe a
little bit your whole family talks with
that a little bit even though maybe you
don't hear it anymore because you've
been around so long do i have an accent
they don't like what happened next yeah
you just said do i have an accent do i
stop it um what happened next no just
after like i just kept having to explain
it to him like no bart's actually like
really reserved and he's very like
to himself so i'm like no don't take it
personal and now he gets it but like for
the long just bummed out didn't your pot
did you tell me your pops was surprised
i just kissed them
excuse me
on the lips
no like you're like uh you know your
dad's all manly as [ __ ] yeah
and then i was like come on trying to
act on manly and i was like what's up
pops i grabbed my kissed him and then he
was like oh yeah
yeah and woke him up so like culturally
uh mexicans are very much like machismo
like man head of the household type of
[ __ ] um so for boyfriends like all the
men always have to kind of like
intimidate a little bit so as soon as my
he met my dad the first thing he does
which you'd never do and no mexican guy
would ever have done this is he just
hugged them and kissed them at me that
was just like what the [ __ ] that was the
first time you met her father
cause he's like i want to be a part of
this
i'd be crazy yeah he said i want to be
espanol you did both
yeah wrong culture bro
but we do do that but after a while or
if you're like family but yeah he did
that right off the bat that's very cute
that's a power movement man in the
bedroom what's the sexiest quality
what's he most talented at oh man
actually what's that what's he good at
actually when you're like i'm climaxing
every time because yeah what's this
technique it's a weird
dialogue what's the finisher i'm about
to make y'all [ __ ] fatality
yeah
so
[Laughter]
geo's like this he's doing
so uh so like i'm i'm not like a fragile
chick right like um i'm pretty tall i'm
pretty sturdy like a two by four
i uh i'm i'm fairly athletic i guess
yeah so like grab ram what do you mean
yes yes sometimes on a good day now
never
so like when we do have sex i actually
like feeling really small so then he'll
just [ __ ] gorilla my ass he does look
like a gorilla picks you up everywhere
that's cool well not really i'm kind of
tall he's like the sex doesn't happen
it's just lifting
i'm crying actually
no sex i just need to feel small right
now
lift me like forklift
pick you up i'll just jack myself up
[Laughter]
you dead lifter
yeah i just give you a piggyback round
rock check my sofa
i like the little hop
a little like is this galloping
oh that's the best but what's his worst
quality then in what what's he better
oh in the bedroom
um in the beginning he's better now but
he actually wasn't very confident like
he just was not about it like he'd be
like oh like he was just like kind of
scared and i'm like what is what this is
technique yeah yeah a little bit scary
tip-toeing everywhere
he likes to feel small too
she wanted him to go like
like a [ __ ] fly you know that but
she's gonna burn that dude she wanted to
joe that
yeah yeah yeah so in the beginning i was
really surprised because he's like
[ __ ] alpha right so like when that
happened i was like
what's going on why is this cool so
gentle have you seen that photo of the
girl holding a [ __ ] flower and
picking at it that's this full runner
dude i gotta tell you this one story i'm
pretty sure you've told it so many times
but uh so one time like we were having
sex and then uh i was telling him to
spank me right so he he's like are you
sure like i don't want to hurt you and
i'm like yeah cause i'm thinking sex
bank right
there's not the bellagio
i know what you're talking about
then he goes okay and he went what and i
just started crying i'm like bro what
the [ __ ] is going on damn
but we we've we've figured it out we
figured it out it's been a lot it's been
many years we got it oh dude it's like
her head smashes into the bellagio glass
it cracks
smashes through the wall oh yeah
it's like no it wasn't domestic violence
i swear it's just troubleshooting you
know what i mean
that's all it is just fine tuning she's
not walking for like two weeks that's
what the relationship is all about fine
tuning jill's like i like rough sex he
goes i got you bro
you put the mouthpiece on
that gear [ __ ] let's go dips it in the
glass
guys he's so literal
[Laughter]
you're just stretching and [ __ ] dancing
glass
[Laughter]
it's a request on the menu this is my
favorite hot seat i think
yeah yeah let's go let's keep going
more of those stories
no i felt so bad
it's weird man because like we're like
doggy style on the floor right what do
you mean we
both of us
you were there you know so like
i spanked her and i never seen anyone
crawl away doggy style that fast
so i went boom and then she was like
awful and then she turns around and
she's crying and i was like and i have a
boner and i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i'm
it's like one of those cartoons where
she runs in place and then takes
you can hear that
you can hear the hanna
barbera and then i think afterwards i
was like are we gonna continue and she
was like are you stupid
i'm like oh she said it like that damn
but then like i went
stupid
picks her back up pops away jacks off
i mean i want to see that's all we have
time for but honestly
you don't come here that often so i
think you should just go for another
five minutes yeah yeah yeah
there you go
it's getting a little hotter push it
push it have you ever thought about
having a threesome with a joe and
barbara oh
hey joe's about to kick your [ __ ]
life but all doggy style
all of us are in doggy style
you know all three of you it's just
three dogs
everyone is just you wanted to turn it
up i mean
she's the bridge in the middle and then
we're doggy what the [ __ ]
geo straps
geo straps on and then barton geo high
five
and i'm the bridge in the middle yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just don't want
okay which way are you facing i'm down
listen listen so it's a rotisserie joke
jotisserie so i'm just i'm down to do it
if joe
uh is fully clothed has blindfold on is
facing the wall we put a sheet over him
he has [ __ ] headphones on we tape his
mouth up then i'm down
that's not fun that's too kinky
he
what if i need to breathe and then he
turns around and takes it all off and
it's david so then what would you say oh
yeah he's softer than me she jumps out
of a building that's what happens i just
imagine i commit to it i should imagine
a geo and joe both on the ground like
this bart smacks them both they both
turn around and cry
it's like tokyo drift yeah and the
teriyaki boys play
and they both just take off
was this the hot seat you were looking
for no
i wanted i want it hotter
what's worse than that go anthony
anthony knows the good questions
personal like real like like for real i
don't know well when was the last time
you cried
dude i cried all the time then that's
not hot
that's not hot when's the last time you
cried and came at the same time cried
and came at the same time have i cried
and came at the same time or cried that
you came
i'm so ashamed
or came that you cried
i look so hot right now oh my god i
flick it
they're kind of flipping
i don't know where this is going but i
like it that's so confusing
you ever have sex with him and imagine
like another celebrity
no and if you did and you had to right
now who would you would it be that's a
good one okay if i had to if i had to
because you already know he's going to
say that person's name next time you
guys are spanking or giving are like
three of them three of them topically i
can't i don't i don't have three but
maybe jason momoa oh
[Music]
yeah but he was aquaman because he's one
of those dudes that if he was boning her
i would be like
oh okay
oh that's what we do
for kind of notepad he's walking around
assumes the position i'm talking
i'll probably be like i'll
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
michael sarah
michael sarah
assumed that would be gilbert godfrey i
mean you want to feel small i don't have
any i don't have the other two no what
about the rock you know like the rifle
yeah
no what yeah he's weird he's hot what
about tom hardy he's pretty hot he is
hot yeah no have you seen his head
wait what about his hands i don't like
his hands
what about it is like uh i don't know
let me see your hands
how about ricky martin he's gay
he is a beautiful man she's trying to
put some diversity in here
how about ricky parker shakira
key regardless
what
that's it that's it thank you for
sharing yeah yeah any time i'm coming
over
geo's unburnable dude i know i'm an open
book
[Music]
you